tras una jornada electoral empañado por
la pandemia las elecciones catalanas se
saldaron con el empate entre el partido
socialista de cataluña y la formación
independentista esquerra repúblicana con
33 escaños cada uno la opción socialista
no logró superar al independentismo como
vaticinaban algunos sondeos a pesar de
ser el partido con más votos no obstante
el candidato salvador y ya calificó los
resultados como una victoria para su
partido la victoria clarísima del psc en
votos
esta noche tiene un significado para mí
muy claro el de pasar página y abrir una
nueva página en cataluña bueno acá una
nueva página de cambio de cambiar para
reencontrarnos dije a todos ustedes que
si ustedes ponían los votos nosotros
pondríamos el cambio y por eso les
quiero anunciar esta noche que
presentaré y me presentaré a la
investidura presidente de la generalitat
la mayoría de los votos en conjunto han
ido para las formaciones
independentistas el partido junts per
cut que docomo la tercera fuerza con 32
escaños
el representante de esquerra repúblicana
pere aragonès aprovechó para mandar un
mensaje a toda europa sobre la necesidad
de un referéndum sit and touch
sentémonos y hablemos los catalanes han
hablado la hora de negociar un
referéndum de autodeterminación ha
llegado por favor impliquen se list
getting go
aunque es sin lugar a duda la gran
sorpresa de esta votación fueron los 11
asientos que logró box facción
ultraderechista situándose como la
cuarta fuerza política la primera vez
que presentaba su candidatura en
cataluña los resultados de estos
comicios son cruciales ya que definirán
si la autonomía es gobernada por un
partido independentista o no un tema que
divide a la sociedad catalana